yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is going to be released I guess on
Christmas Eve which is a bit unusual
watches video to be released but it's
them the last day that I have before I'm
going to go travel to my tournament in
Poland in Krakow so it's about the only
thing I can do it yeah it would have to
wait like two weeks oh and then that I
didn't want to do so let's get going I
want to get you let's say informed about
my latest project that is going to be
released on
chasuble in early 2018
it is almost finished let's say I think
the total completion is about 85 to 90
percent of the whole thing I'm still
writing on it working on it analyzing
but I have everything like together and
know what lines the the book on chasuble
would have it's just some fine-tuning
and some some writing it will be
finished in January and then we will
yeah get it get it out as soon as
possible to be released on chasuble
and probably also other media formats
we'll see I want to give you know you
what will be in the repertoire it's an e
for repertoire so let's put it on the
board
and the title will be something like
this the 1.e4 keep it simple repertoire
this is one of my favorite mottos and
chance anyway I think people tend to
over complicate things doing the simple
things well in chess is a really really
good way of approaching it so this
repertoire features lines that are
reasonably simple to learn simple to
understand and ideally still successful
potentially successful weapons in many
cases I'm going for lines that have
good theoretical reputation but don't
necessarily the sharpest possible way of
playing in some cases I'm going for
something that is more like a little bit
more technical maybe I'm going for lines
where you have very low risk of losing
but have chances to press for more if
the other side does something yeah too
ambitious or simply to the to lose let's
have an overview of what I'm going to
recommend in the repertoire so one ephod
unlike d4 c4 Knight of three openings
with one e form things are very very
systematically are very little
transpositions between the first move so
you need a weapon against e5 one against
c5 one against is six and so on and they
don't really interfere so much with one
another let's go E 5 I'm going to
recommend to go Knight f3 and I'm
covering I mean you're covering
everything yeah I will give you
something against even the crazy opening
so the Latvian the the elephant gambit
like this and everything everything will
be in there the holy for business um
still what is the main the main thing
here it will be 96 that's going to be
happening in the most most often so my
recommendation is to play Knight c3 in
this position in order to go for the
four Knights Scotch for Knights this
line has a reputation of being extremely
solid for white which means it's tough
to break down the usual way of handling
this is this variation where black
ultimately frees himself with d5 and
after the capture and Age 3 followed by
Queen f3 there is a line on the board
that has a very very sound reputation
for white it's one of those very very
low risk
ways of playing and still exerting a
little bit of pressure the good thing
about this opening is and this is the
same thing with many other lines that
I'm going to recommend it is
strategically extremely sound you have
absolutely no pawn weakness you have the
pawns here are basically ideally placed
you have good open piece play I would
rarely recommend a line where you have a
problem piece where you have a space
disadvantage where you have to handle
extremely difficult strategic situations
it will be sometimes simple but it will
always be good and easy to play this is
one of the virtues of this line and you
have very easy player either plank which
I have three Bishop f4 develop quickly
and try to exert some pressure on blacks
slightly weakened pawn structure if you
play this line here the four Knights
Scotch you have a ready-made answer to
the petrov by going Knight c3 here the
move knight c6 is probably just the best
move and the only meaningful standalone
thing independent thing but people
should be form but after the capture
white is slightly better this is
theoretically established basically
forever and nothing super special but
white gets the bishop at a more
comfortable game so you're killing two
birds with one stone here basically you
have a weapon against a petrov and
against 96 the good thing about having
this here in your repertoire this
position is that you can very easily and
one point at the regular Scotch to your
repertoire after which Knight f6 you
would be able to play very solid he was
Knight c3 which is we have in Europe try
anyway or you could take on c6 and play
the sharp misses variation so my
recommendation is something that could
be easily used later as the base for
like expanding the repertoire this is
what I recommend
five note that everything else will also
be there like no black playing g6
or here or d6 or what not yeah I'm
giving something against all those
sidelines as well so this is 185
the other main move of course is the
Sicilian those two will comprise a lot
of your games against Sicilian I
recommend to go on idea three and I have
a reasonably simple recipe there black
will now most of the time play the moves
D 6 e 6 on 96 these far the most common
moves and it's actually quite simple if
black go was knight c6 I'm recommending
to play Bishop b5 the so called
rustle demo variation if their gold is 6
again I recommend we should be 5 in this
case we should be 5 check it's got the
Moscow variation and against any other
move basically that does not attack e4
against Knight f6 of course we have to
do something about this but against
other moves like a 6 g 6 or 6 I'm going
to recommend to play C 3 so for example
e 6 and recommending C 3 the reason why
I'm recommending C 3 only here on move
three animals too is that with the moves
that black plays like e6000
he is always going to yea give up some
options that are very viable against 2 C
3 for example if you go to 3 which is
not a bad move in its own right but like
for example it has many lines available
that involve putting the bishop actively
outside of the pawn chain here and this
is of course completely out of the
picture after a 63 also a 63 you can
argue that this is on
the loss of tempo it's not like that
easy but yeah c3 is generally believed
to be best against the a6 anyway now the
move would be g6 again there's c3 what
I'm recommending so I like to build up
the c3 d4 Center but under let's say
yeah using our own terms they're not
playing along and giving black all the
options that are potentially okay in
them moscow variation here just to
complete the picture we will set up set
up Amarok see by information very much a
good poor information with good chances
for white to actually yeah put some
pressure on black this is not just
simple equality I think with those lines
there has been a pretty pretty
substantial revaluation in recent years
yeah influenced by games by by Magnus
cards and some other players
I think people take this more seriously
now that that was believed to be
somewhat dryish but I don't think it is
you can just play for win with this
isn't it
in the Rosso Nemo there are many complex
lines most often black plays ecigs and
g6 in both cases I don't recommend to
capture on c6 but play with castles and
just develop of course you can take him
after g6 you can take here this is
Africa this is advice but many books and
it's not bad at all
but I wanted lines where don't give up
the bishop pair or that easily we have a
more fluid development I thought that
was a strategically easier to play a lot
of this is about taste and personal
preference note that if you learn the
the lines that I'm suggesting here
you're not completely tied to a certain
type of game for example if you play
Bishop b5 and after g6 you somehow think
that
I'm recommending to play like this
somehow you don't like this so much you
prefer to take out six then you're
welcome to do so this is a very
respectable mainline and the advantage
of playing main lines is that you have a
variety of options if you stuck with
some obscure line you sometimes just
have a very narrow path that it's
actually possible to walk in the first
place with the main line you have order
all the options to to vary you play so
against it Sicilian I don't have the
open Sicilian this is an overkill yeah
do that in a keep it simple repertoire
and it's not necessary at all white
enjoys good chances for small pull
against Bishop with Bishop b5 as well it
is actually there are many people who
think that this is actually better than
d4 if you look at this rationing call
for example you know what I'm talking
about here you probably have more
chances to keep a long term long term
pressure on black yeah this is a
Sicilian the next one is the Carol um
against I'm which I'm recommending the
tonight's variation this has been a
favorite line of mine for a long time I
mean I'm not playing before that often
but I always thought that this line has
some yeah has some real credibility one
reason is that many players score
bishops you form that is a traditional
main move and after that we're either
going to get the bishop pair on five
that is really early and with the bishop
pair we have an idea of what to play for
yeah I could
long-term advantage of the two bishops
I'm not saying that this is terrible for
black but you can certainly claim with
precise play that white has a small
advantage and again you know what your
advantage is it's not like some yeah
undefined struggle where you try little
things you know okay I've got the bishop
pair if we can open up the position or
if you can get a favorable pawn
structure and the bishops would have
their same um some people go here which
is sharp but probably not entirely
correct yeah after what takes check it's
it's the technical stuff but it's not
great so so played by many players
there's also a trap part of it this is
not a good line after ninety three
Bishop to six and age four like has some
substantial problems to stay in the game
so surprising the awkwardness yeah and
there are some funny funny ideas here
for example this is a recent trend but
Queen e2 is actually interesting move
I've had this played against me indeed
young funny and funny and the two nights
is quite respectable ready and played by
many good players ninety six is the
modern trend the most recent main was
probably after which II 594 9 2 is my
recommendation I actually believe that
black is probably equalizing there or
gets very close at least but I think
it's still there's no reason to not
playing this with white it's an
interesting position and a good way of
finding the Carroll is I think nicely
meta with the two knights now probably
my most controversial choice and I
really had some some comments about this
that were less not not very friendly
okay the French defense against the
French
I'm going to recommend to play the
exchange variation this is something
that did not occur to me when I started
the project not at all
I had started out intending to recommend
the tirage 90 to the terrace variation
is of course a good line and if you are
looking for objective truth chess
probably 92 or 93 will be the best moves
there however there is there are some
points that are really making exd5 quite
interesting after 92 black actually has
a choice of lion and his choice of lion
were largely influenced the upcoming
game if he takes only form or if he
plays c5 or 96 or we should be seven or
Knight f6 or whatever he's like he's got
eight or nine moves and they will all be
somewhat different and black is the one
choosing the line and choosing in some
case in some cases the pawn structure it
is actually difficult to learn because
there are so many different setups and
then when looking through the database I
was kind of uh none satisfied with the
tirage because of that wide variety
variety of lines then then I suddenly
recognized that the world champion
Magnus Carlsen actually had played a
number of games recently in the French
exchange mostly in rapid chess and I
felt was always worth exploring but
Magnus history so I looked in it and
there were interesting ideas in fact
it's not like they will completely
change the chess world those ideas but
they both black some little problems
really they really do especially in the
lines that I always felt are critical I
absolutely I was never really doubting
that let's say after Knight and three
Bishop g4 or their widest
I think this is also commonly commonly
known or xe5 for example it's a bad
there are many ways to to play badly
with black Bishop d6 e4 I think white
has reasonable chances for slide
advantage this is I'm also not a big
surprise the line that was mostly at
least for me a critical one was simply
the the pure symmetry got just black
copies white and this is the the line
that usually sees this huge drawing
percentage them here what Carson is
doing as he plays Queen 2e to check and
this is surprisingly interesting if
black in our place the normal movement I
think this will be the the the main
choice in in over the board games Queen
to e7 I think white already has some
advantage because after the capture him
and saying yeah both captures a possible
of course twin takes castles and white
is going to play rook e1 check tempo and
he's got some easy temples here who
might play a B 3 C 4 this is just not
equal I understand the Queen's are off
and it's symmetrical but I mean I have
tried this in blitz chess for example
and I've won almost all my games it's
just like white is a little bit better
there's no question about that the same
thing this actually with bishop takes
after which in Ernie Bishop f4 is
harassing the C pawn it if you go c6
here with black and white castles I mean
white is quicker here don't
underestimate that yeah you can easily
run into a position that looks
absolutely boring but it's in fact just
a lot better for white like this
position for example yeah if you're just
like I'm going to double on the ephah
whatever are you doing here with those
pieces this is awkward it's not easy
Carlton has won those positions very
convincingly in rapid chess against very
good grandmasters so I completely
understand you say ah isn't that boring
yeah well I'm it depends
I think it's just a matter of men off of
choice you can play a very complicated
French middle game against many players
you will be the one understanding it
worse because they have their clothes
French positions say like this or 93 and
9 of 65 on the board all the time and
they will have an advantage usually in
knowledge of structure and with the
capture this is over you're basically
telling the guy you're not going to get
your clothes yeah maneuvering
positionally going to play an open game
let's see how you do with that and and
also don't underestimate some people
think after 85 white is playing for a
draw and then the black players will not
be as circumspect as they should be or
even better be over-ambitious and if
black is over-ambitious here he will be
punished quite severely there are some
ambitious lines that simply don't work
so before you think oh my god this is
terrible
have a look at the lines I was surprised
I'm really not sending some something
stupid to you that I feel as bad I would
definitely play the exchange over the
board I wouldn't really mind it at all
it's maybe not a weapon that you want to
use for for the whole of your chest
career maybe at some point you'll see
okay let's play Knight c3 instead on
move three or 92 but the exchange is
extremely solid will always be a useful
thing to have in your repertoire
sometimes a simple position is the
better choice and when I compared the
positions that I analyzed like out of
the exchange with some other positions
and ahead out of the taraji so I really
didn't feel it's a big difference
especially in the context of a
repertoire that wants to avoid huge
chunks of theory if you play one of the
mainline Frenchy's with the idea in mind
to not play every single theoretical
move up to move 30 you won't have
anything anyway it's just what it is so
you can I think rather try to pray
a bit in exchange then do it in some
polylines I'm already happy with my
recommendation even though I've gotten
some flack already on forums and so on
before doing this anyway
I think it's a good choice um yeah those
are the the big form the big four
openings that you will face most of the
time I can give you an idea what I do
against the others we have I have one
chapter about d6g six these kind of
things against the pills I'm
recommending to play like this it's a
very interesting line why does some yeah
supporting the center and securing
against Nigerian case of a slow black
build-up and most of the time they play
quite slowly like this for example we're
going to push f4 and be very aggressive
this is I think a much improved version
of the f4 lines of the Austrian attack
that we also see often where white
pushes a form on move five here the
black is committed to something Lane
which is six already age three is
actually very useful yeah sometimes you
can go here and you are very very same
again slightly for you of course I think
this is a good setup and I'm
recommending this against basically
anything with d6 g6m no matter if they
start not b6 or g6 and always opt for
yeah this kind of this kind of setup and
I think it's just okay for what in some
cases it's better for white a lot better
even if black knows everything inside
out is maybe somewhat okay but this is
just what it is if they played perfectly
yeah cannot do it much but I think
excellent chances for an advantage I
would have one chapter on the
Scandinavian that proved to be
surprisingly difficult to tackle
actually I was somewhat stunned that
there are so many different variations
that black can play especially when
you're here they've got queenie 526
queen d8 and these lines are
fundamentally at times different some
motifs are similar but you have to
really look at every single move in
detail I was surprised when I think I
found some good things black is simply
not equalizing in the Scandinavian and
it's not very surprising I mean it's not
a mainline opening but it is not so easy
for white it's not like you can learn
something in two minutes and be fine I
could one chapter about the the rest
yeah then stuff like the other kinds be
696 and so on this side line chapter is
actually the chapter that is not yet
written I know what I'm going to
recommend I think the only one that is
of some interest may be enough for you
to know is what I do against the
Ellicott's
I'm going to recommend the exchange
variation this is much easier to play
than for Knight f3 for a sideline
I don't know playing a super main line
is probably not the way to go so I'm
happy with this and against like yeah
the the bad openings like b6 and so on
there are no one refutation that nor
antidotes um I think I've covered
everything yeah or did I miss some some
opening I don't think so um again I'm
working on it most of it is completed
for example the holy 45 complex is
completely written and ready ready to go
the Sicilian is like 90% completed the
carro is completed the French is 90%
completed s on there there's some there
are some things missing but nothing that
will take ages to complete we're talking
about one
weeks maybe yeah and then this is ready
to be released and looking forward to it
again it's not completely clear where
this is going to be so be accessible
that's clear but there will be maybe
additional channels to release it we
will see we're working we're working on
things yeah I think this was a good wave
of introducing to you to my project team
on them it's going to be released on
just about the e-form project I also
make this video for an additional thing
that is related to chasuble they have a
new book out there not by me but some
other authors that I think is
interesting for you to check out I'm
going to load the chasuble website I
hope that I did not really prepare this
or that thoroughly
it just like let me let me log in and
see yeah this is the book this is the
book let me have a look it is this one
here
um can you see that actually mmm no that
doesn't help
it's 1001 chess exercises for beginners
so it's the first release about tactics
ready on chesil we go in there we'll see
that this is based on a real book paper
book by frank uma Sethi and Roberta mess
up so what are we talking about you this
is 1001 chess puzzles technical puzzles
and it's aimed at people who are I mean
I don't think it's fair to say for
beginners maybe like when you're a
little bit behind the beginner stage and
a little bit better then this could be a
book for you and a chasuble product for
you they start with I know don't don't
be a don't laugh at people we've made
one made in one and then it gets more
complicated it is actually a tactical
course in Texas and tactics so it starts
with all the motifs and the difference
is with this 1001 exercise positions
compared to a tactics trainer it is that
those these positions have been selected
so that they cover all the motifs so
it's it's about learning all the motifs
not just about solving relatively random
positions so at the end of this course
it should be absolutely made sure that
you have seen all the motifs you will
have seen tons of pins and skewers and
just cover the text and so on and so on
it's a really interesting way of doing
it instead of doing it on a tactics
trainer if you look into into this how
it works on chasuble you have those
those chapters and you can click on we
can also do the whole the whole thing
from the very first position to the last
we can also go into certain things and
then we will learn next you get you get
get the positions they have the whole
text yeah I did skip that now I
shouldn't have done that it was a little
bit too much a little bit too quick
where they explained the concept of what
a discovered check actually is yeah
think about the target group it's not
aimed at grandmasters okay here you have
to find if five which is not so
difficult and we win the bishop and the
game so I should have solved that one
next lesson and you get get the next
position again I discovered attack here
the bishop is lined up on the King so
you find this and you will actually win
this and win the game here with the
extra piece and important to the form on
c3 so these were actually quite easy but
it gets more difficult I mean at the end
of it you get many positions that are
tricky to solve
not just for beginners but rather for
more advanced players and one
interesting point about this is and this
is something that I would like to look
into a little bit more when I have time
I don't have much time because I'm
living yeah I'm on my train heading east
and nine hours exactly so I don't have
that much time
an interesting thing could be to use
this set of tactics for the song
so-called woodpecker method yeah the
woodpecker the animal the woodpecker
method was coined by the Grandmaster
Hans chicken and I think and was
introduced to me in the book pump up
your rating by XL Smith where chicken
and says that he improved a lot by
solving relatively basic technical
problems over and over again and maybe
the set of problems here could be used
there that that would be something for
stronger players then but I need to look
at the positions more and I also made me
need to meet up on some things relating
to the woodpecker method would
recommended and maybe you can go that
there's some discussion on it in online
forums like on on reddit for example
maybe this is usable for this purpose
I'm not entirely sure it's definitely
useful book if you want the basic
tactics book and just want to go through
all of them if you go through those 1001
puzzles you would definitely be a better
better technical player especially when
you are in that playing level range
let's say fourteen fifteen hundred this
kind of this kind of ranges um so it can
be useful for higher level players I
guess if you yeah may be employed in the
this woodpecker man woodpecker
woodpecker method it's a really
difficult wood I don't want to explain
this method to you now and just look it
up if you're interested and know
I've heard about it yeah surge ready to
search the forums yeah so these are some
news on that what's going on on chesil
and with my project I hope you enjoyed
this this update and I hope you would
have good Christmas days and a good
start into 2018 I'll be back in 2018
after returned from a tournament in
Poland with new content on the channel
definitely yeah and it's not a an empty
promise I will do more stuff there what
exactly we're going to see again thanks
to all of you and I'll be back next year
bye bye